classique et nous en sommes non non non
ce n'est pas un homme oui le deal est
voulue l'excès de quelqu'un sur ce
plateau non non ça va se corser je vous
ai dit ça va se corser gym êtes vous
très jeune vous avez
vous du poils sur les bras
et j'ai voulu c'est qu'on va me faire le
bien va me faire la soirée on va passer
des bras aux jambes et des jambons bras
je vous le dis regardez regardez cette
petite tête chelem parce qu'il est
content il a milli content s'il est
content - cette question est ce que vous
venez pour un homme non ça élimine déjà
quatre personnes autour de la gare donc
c'est au pont magali autorisa ou pour
lui
l'outil sexuelle est-ce que c'est sexuel
invité mystère non ben salah hésiter un
malaise y
être que sa faillite sexuelles non non
je propose qu'on regarde un premier avis
parce que chan classe c'est un peu un
piquet jr et je vous ai dit celui-ci
d'état s'est corsée ben oui c'est pas 6e
ex
une colombe ils ont battu au lombard et
mathieu mathieu et donjon se cachent
pour mourir ce que c'est une question
moi très intelligente on dispute avec la
personne parce que la colombe c'est la
paix normalement nara donc est ce que
vous êtes en dispute
[Musique]
et la surface bien et la maison parce
qu'elle sait on a dit que c'était une
simple parce que j'ai surtout découvert
c'est que maladie magali berda tire les
cartes tous les jours et heures à 10
heures mais c'est surtout que c'est
beaucoup d'ennemis est-ce que vous avez
des animals à moi j'en ai un mais
quelques-uns huawei est ce qu'il ya des
ennemis avec lesquels vous aimeriez vous
rabibocher nom
de sa chance
regardez
ça la vraie colomb de lauzun colombe de
la paix monnaies si ça donne à jean
michel aulas pour magali berda non
appelés pour une réconciliation oui
deuxième indice ah ouais parce que j'ai
des deux mondes ici
[Musique]
j'avoue le dire les avis parce que je la
connais par coeur ce que c'est vraiment
une amie de coeur et jaur m ludivine
réthoré bron est en panique
se disant qui ça peut bien être est ce
que c'était un truc de réconciliation
s'est pas dit est ce que je connais
votre caractère justement il faut la
télé parfois pour aider mon caractère un
peu difficile ajustement se réconcilier
écoutez moi 7 7 7 cette soirée a eu des
maîtresses et lente cette soirée une
thématique l'amour l'amour amour et moi
je ne souhaite que l'amour oui je
souhaite que l'amo la bienveillance que
des gens se retrouvent un zizou est ce
que la fâcherie date de très longtemps
et très profonde non agim question qui
va peut-être nous guider à avez vous
fait un long voyage pour venir à parce
que moi non
bah oui je te chauffes
troisième attention les amis là ses
troisièmes et derniers avis parce que je
sens que reda les pas qui c'est un sur
dix non non vous verrez troisième indice
ces gens là m'ont pas là on touche pas à
mon poste lui colombo et dans bruit
d'ici là il en bronze et une embrouille
d'ici réfléchissez et une colombe mais
elle a beaucoup hein mais c'est sa
meilleure amie c'est pas pour benjamin
adam palumbo n'empêche
il écouté pas mal pas longs ballons bas
quoi on balance un oui mais mais en
l'occurrence ça concerne donc deux
femmes on a éliminé magali well i rèss
ludivine ou isabelle moi je vais te
manger vrai que c'est toi il abat oui il
est ce que vous pensez que c'est pour
vous
non d'aller au mondial s est pas du tout
que c'était pour moi mais vous dites
touche pas mon pass donc j'essaie oui on
va découvrir tout de suite c'est avec
quelqu'un touche pas à mon pote ki vien
fou
déjà déjà est-ce que sans même savoir la
personne sans même savoir la personne
est ce que parce que je vous connais il
à vous êtes plutôt du genre à ne pas
aimer être en froid avec quelques arrêts
ce que d'ores et déjà ça vous dirait de
voilà j'aurai des ennemis que je ne
connais pas c'est possible on va
découvrir ça immédiatement faire cela
peut-il bien être la révélation c'est
tout cela
[Applaudissements]
manière quand même qui fait un truc
extra que daniel est en plein deuil tu
jouais avec plaisir à venir
habillé pour venir certaines mauvaises
de revenir de son deck cinq minutes pour
parler avec isabelle mais parce qu'elle
a quelque chose à vous dire patrick
damian s'il vous plaît les amis riches
isa et daniel on sait qu' il y à un
homme entre vous ah oui cet homme alors
demande trop nabawi cet homme c'est un
petit bar but tu m'as revenait à petit
ses profonds dans la cité vellave
pourtant
un grand barbu talentueux génial
ingénieur en génie le monsieur cyril
hanouna oui visiblement la détention
daniel nous a contactés en nous disant
je sens qu'il ya quelque chose avec et
avec isa et je ne veux absolument pas
parce que j'aime beaucoup et isabelle et
j'ai une déclaration à lui faire et par
conséquent des
machines il venait de bône à côté de moi
venez manière
d'évaluer
moi
voilà allez-y c'est votre moment
dernière je m'éclipse parce qu'il s'agit
d'un moment important c'est vrai et puis
en plus nos téléspectateurs même pas
vous savoir fâché parce que tp c'est une
grande famille
on vous laisse le petit malentendu et
j'ai une proposition alors je les fais
en alexandrins ce sont des verts du
xviie siècle c'est là le sienna moines
et ça commence mal et enfin de dire
qu'elle peut être d'utile entre les deux
géants alors pour me rabibocher je te
propose un deal je te laisse hanouna
mais moi je garde cyril choisi
l'animateur et je prends l'animal à toi
les beaux discours pour moi les nuits
d'amour en actu lève la jambe
j'écarterai les bras
[Applaudissements]
que tu étais beaucoup de choses mais là
on va me faire du chat botté j'ai un
côté là je suis plus tout jeune j'ai
tout de finir
tu feras des débats moi j'aurai les
ébats je te laisse le petit tu seras
baby sitter mais à moi les folies après
lors d une heure
[Applaudissements]
mais après après c'est à isabelle ça
isabelle de décider le petit c'est
toujours serré
mais
qu'est ce que vous pensez de cette
déclaration de cette menteuse girl et de
ce partage des petits tas nous l'a
peut-être à son bord deux
mais pas moi oui je passe à
cette année
gagner alors je me permets je peux vous
appeler tatie danielle je suis même en
mer à nouveau parce que je suis à airtel
dans tatie danielle
c'est très joli c'est très joliment
tourné ce vocable x oui ah oui c'est
bien bien écrit bien
perçu
j'adore les années qu'ils accordent à
aider même si
on en connaît toutes les deux le roi
soleil
je suis très partageuse de nature
comment vous dit alors c'est vrai qu'on
aime les mêmes personnes généralement
morte à cnet france arrangé ses affaires
on aime toutes les 2 cyril qui
apparemment nous a pour l'instant refusé
toutes les deux un nécessaire d'espérer
pour entreprendre ni de réussir pour
persévérer
donc moi je veux bien contenté de la
partie émergée de l'iceberg et je vous
laisse tout le reste comme je veux
plessisville à l'eau frérot est bien
dans ses sauts alors il parait qu il
paraît qu'il ya qu un poste c'est
nouveau mais alors tu sais quoi vous
savez quoi tatie danielle si vraiment
vous le voulez ce poste et si c'est
n'est d'accord mais je vous laisse
c'est toutes les
maisons on peut faire les soeurs
jumelles moi je suis je suis j'adore ça
les vamps peuvent se rangeant prend pas
le petit bisou de l'amitié
[Applaudissements]
aulas
nick encore là oui c'est vrai non non il
y avait un truc est encore là
[Applaudissements]
[Rires]
les lots pour
isabelle weill zamind pas honteux par
l'ademe te parle sakhaline par les six
et moi vraiment fort non mais en forme
d'accords l'aisne en mairie comme aux
lois qui hélas a dessiné la la c'est ma
is as que c'est fait que ce petit petite
main tendue de la part d'isabelle vous
savez que cyril qui nous regardent et
qui vous aime toutes les deux avec
passion il voulait vivre d'être sur wii
il vous aide oui il vous aime il vous
adore toutes les deux vraiment et il ne
veut pas dans les boues savait qu'il
devait sachant l'équipier des
chamailleries des fâcheries ça donc on
est bien d'accord que tout va bien pour
toutes les deux noms
mais puis en plus oui vous serez toutes
les deux dans tpm paix voilà regardez là
ce soir vous étiez toutes les doses en
émission oui mais le problème ici
à la
monture sa mâture en train de réfléchir
sur l'amour de syrie le pourcentage non
mais c'est 50 50 50 pour vous cinquante
pour isawi alors ben oui pourquoi vous
vouliez 70/30 non marchands de tapis